let me ask you about the fourth
thing in facet
face of jiu-jitsu which is uh
self-defense
let's say the bigger things i don't know
if you
you know i don't know why it's called
self-defense it's called street fighting
let's call it fighting okay maybe maybe
you can contest us that terminology how
about
non-sport fighting non-sports funny like
street fighting what happens if you go
out on a playground you're fighting on
grass they're no longer street fighting
it's like tennis you have like wimbledon
like grass courts and
it's a whole other thing uh no is there
um
what do you think is the best martial
art for street fighting
what is the best set of uh we talked
about advice
for white belts to advance in
in uh in grappling in jiu jitsu
what is the set of techniques maybe
martial art that is best
for street fighting okay um again
you're asking some truly fascinating
questions here
um
the way this gets framed as a question
is often
condemns you to bad answers from the
start
this is uh as a questioner i'm i'm
trying to achieve
asymmetry of power and i'm winning
[Laughter]
um put you in a bad position
don't worry so much about people always
gonna say you know is this martial art
better or is this martial arts better
the truth is uh
there's only one way to say this
combat sports are your best option for
self-defense
there are many martial arts and there is
a rough divide between
the two those that fall into combat
sports and those that
fall into non-sporting
martial arts where there's no
uh competitive
live sparring element where
most of the knowledge is limited to
theoretical knowledge reinforced by
passive drilling
if you have a choice between a combat
sport versus
a non-sporting art based around
theoretical knowledge and passive
drawing
go with a combat sport nothing
will prepare you for the intensity
of a genuine altercation better
than combat sports
many people as i say these words are
probably
horrified to hear me say this and uh uh
immediately going to rebut and say no
combat sports is exactly the wrong thing
for you to do
because they have safety rules etc etc
which
would easily be exploited in a real
fight and if i fought a world
championship
boxer i would just poke him in the eye
or kick him in the groin etc
you heard these arguments a thousand
times um yes there is
some validity to these things but as a
general rule
if you ask me to bet in any form of
street fight call it what you want
between
a combat sport adherent versus someone
who
simply trains with drills and
talks in terms of theories of what they
would do in a fight
i'm going to go with the combat sport
guy every single
time now having said that
combat sports need to be modified
for the use of self-defense street fight
and we haven't agreed on it to him yet
we'll figure it out later
what does this modification consist of
well
some of it is technical okay for example
a boxer and a street fight now has to
punch
without wrapped or gloved hands and
that's problematic
okay your hands are not really designed
for heavy extended use of clubbing hard
objects there's a very high likelihood
of breaking your hands
mike tyson was one of the finest
punchers that ever lived
but in one of his more famous street
fights against mitch green
in the night late 1980s he broke his
hand
with one punch that he threw his
opponent hit the wrong part of the head
and broke his hand he was one of the
most gifted punches of all time
if he can do it you'll certainly have
trouble protecting your hands
and when you go to throw blows
nonetheless this is easily modified and
so a boxer can throw with with
open hands or with elbows and so just a
small modification and technique
can overcome that problem so what you'll
find
is that the general physical
mental conditioning and skill
development that comes from combat
sports
allied with technical
modifications and then the most
important of all
tactical modifications will provide your
best
hope in altercations
outside of sports in the street or
wherever you find yourself
the least effective approaches to
self-defense that i have observed in my
life
have been those where as i said people
talked theory drilled on passive
opponents
and generally had no engagement in
live competition or sparring in their
training programs
the most effective by a landslide
were those that put a heavy emphasis on
live sparring and sporting competition
modified both technically and tactically
for the circumstances in which they
found themselves
people talk for example about how you
know um
and with some validity that that weapons
will change everything in a
in a street fight there's absolute truth
to that but this extends into weapons as
well
okay the most effective
forms of of knife fighting that you'll
see will be those who
come from a background in fencing
because it has
sparring and a competitive sport aspect
to it but would
pure fencing be the appropriate thing of
course not you'd have to modify it
but the reflexes endurance physical
mobility that you gain from the sport of
fencing could
easily be modified to play craft in a in
a fight situation
what you want to look for with regards
street and self-defense is not okay
which style should i choose should i
choose taekwondo should i choose karate
should i choose
this variation of kung fu no focus on
the most important thing
does it have a sport aspect to it then
once you've made sufficient progress in
the sport aspect of that martial art
start asking yourself what are the
requisite modifications and technique
and tactics that i have to
to use or to input
to make it effective for street
situations that's always the advice that
i give
you